I have never shared my drugs with anyone in my entire life. I
use drugs personally and my drugs are for me exclusively and
that's just the facts. So your boyfriend had this conversation.
Hold on. You tied this
convers because your boyfriend wouldn't convert and you couldn't
get turned on and you felt like that wased up, right? That really
was not a problem. now. Oh, he's on. Somebody already on banned
him. Okay, here. I'm going to move these people in. Riy, I extreme
dad. What's up, guys? How's it going? Hello. How's it going?
How's it going? I'm pretty.
Okay, what are we doing here? There's a debate between Riyle
and Extreme Dad. Yep. Hey, so Extreme Dad called me out in Ieko's
Iiko chat or something like that. You know, I normally would
like to get a debate topic, but I think, you know, giving him
the advantage by giving me a surprise with the debate topic,
I think, is fair enough. I think Extreme Dad always has, you
know, something interesting to say. So, Extreme Dad, can you
tell us why we're here? Well, I do my very best to be entertaining
um for you guys and your audiences. Um, at the end of the day,
that's why I'm always here. It isn't to win or lose or be right
or wrong. It's to be entertaining for your guys' viewers. So,
I'm glad to hear you say that to see it face. Um, the main thing
that I I take issue with is your classification or or um
your video title of me and regarding me as a Destiny Defender.
I think that um you again you are taking up you clearly disagree
with me but I mostly object to you disagreeing with me and seeing
me or identifying me as a Destiny defender or essentially breaking
down my argument to just defending Destiny, you know, like that's
not at all what I was doing. That's not at all what happened
and that's not the case.
Gotcha. So, if I can kind of understand what you're saying, you're
saying when you came in making those defenses, you don't necessarily
agree that Destiny is a bad guy or a good guy. You were making
just neutral opinions and arguing those points based on the facts
of the case. Yeah. I mean, like Destiny and I are mortal enemies.
You know, he him and I he's referred to me as a violent, unpredictable
psychopath and I've threatened to kill him. Can I ask that's
crazy, but can I ask why that would matter? How much you like
Destiny or not when people are reacting to like the what you
were saying? Because you're saying that I'm defending him as
though it's like he's my
uh you know streamer man and I'm here to [__] defend
him at all costs regardless of what the truth of the matter is.
I'm right and y'all are wrong. Okay. So, okay. True. By be by
minimizing that into just and and categorizing it as just destiny
as a defense of destiny, you're taking away from the the validity
and the righteousness of my argument. You guys are dead wrong.
Everything that you're saying or believe is complete fantasy.
Okay? It will never happen. It will never happen. What do you
think would happen? Can I Let's Hold up before we get there.
But the fact of the matter is let him cook. Just because I'm
coming on and saying that like, "Hey, you're wrong and what you're
saying will not come to pass." That does not mean that I am defending
Destiny. Now, I have my own opinion about just how bad what he
did was, but I like I am in no way defending his actions or saying
that like, you know, just because I think that what he did was
less bad than you, that's not a defense of him. just because
I think that the action in and of itself removed from, you know,
Destiny and just as an action that one could take is not that
bad. That does not mean that I'm defending his actions or saying
anything in regards to or that would amount to a defense of his
behavior. Okay. So, um, when you were mentioning that, um, Pixie
sending nudes to Destiny gave him Cart Blanch to share with other
people. Now, from what I understand, she didn't necessarily send
him nudes as much as participated in the creation of a video
with him. Is that correct? I I would say that's probably the
like the crux of the issue. So, you all matter. Uh you probably
think it does actually. I think that it matters a great deal.
In fact, why would it matter whether whether or not it was sent
to him? Let's just give that to him. Let's just give that to
him. Okay, we'll just give that to him that he he participate,
you know, she did participate in videos and we can focus on that's
probably the one created a video that was shared with an with
a third party and correct. Are you and what was their question
again? I'm sorry. I'm I'm so um so they they
they they co-created uh an adult film or video, right? And then
when that was created, do you feel Destiny then sending that
to other people other you know without Pixie's permission was
bad? Do you think that's a bad thing to do? Well, um and I you
know if the
was yes or no and then you can explain why. Yes. Yes, it's bad.
Okay, good. We're making good ground. So, now go ahead and explain.
Now, how bad it is
varies. I mean, just how much was the
um you know, point expressed that this is for no one but us.
This is to be shared, you know, by or this is like to never be
shared. It's for your eyes only. This is something private we
are making. and it better not get out. You know, just how
explicit was the belief that this was not to be seen by anyone
else on Pixie side of things. Just how much consent was actually
violated here? Because what I think that any reasonable party
would understand when you are creating co-creating a explicit
piece of con content with another person is that the risk and
the possibility that that is going to be seen by other people
is always present. Okay. Where's the or cuz there's a risk with
everything. Like and so with that
understanding your drug dealer might give you too much and have
fentanyl and totally you know and life is all about something
you might be familiar with right life is all about managing risk
you ran into that situation right let's not distract from the
point here we can get to that after the fact where let's not
fair enough so I'm just saying like so you know and that that
Pixie has been completely
absolved of any responsibility for having engaged in behavior
that has risk associated with it and that you know nobody wants
to place any sort of responsibility on her for having this content
available to be shared is is asinine and ridiculous. But the
fact of the matter is Destiny, who is a participant in the video,
never identified the other party. He never said this is a video
of Pixie. He never clarified just who it was, and he never intended
for it to be seen with anyone other than the individuals he shared
it with privately. Okay, let's say let's say Destiny was with
Pixie's mom and he only intended to send that video
analogies. Let's not say anything. Let's debate what actually
think about what he would feel like if he didn't have breakfast
this morning. No, it's just it's such a distraction. Can we talk
about what actually happened? Okay. Something that actually happened
there's enough to sell drugs to somebody's cause them to overdose.
That's not true. Just like but they should have known. What you're
saying is not a risk. There was a risk when they bought those
drugs that they I have never sold drugs to anyone in my entire
life. They're just trying. This is exactly what you guys are
doing to Destiny. Oh, he's such a bad guy. Therefore, it doesn't
matter to think that he's guilty. No, but you're doing the same
thing to Destiny he's doing to me right now. I'm not. You're
saying his actions are my argument here. You're in here basically
saying that Destiny u meeting all elements of a specific statute
is not a reason he should be found guilty of that statute and
that I'm crazy for suggesting that. Basically, you're saying
that the way all Commonwealth law works is incorrect. You're
arguing the entire American legal system is incorrect. That's
the argument you're making. I think that's probably insane. But
I'm going to let you go ahead and argue with Riyle. So, go ahead.
My argument is is that what Destiny did was bad and that he should
have not done it, but there is not a godamn thing anyone knew
about it legally. I don't think you heard a single crimally.
It's very entertaining. It's incredible. Ethany has no legal
or criminal. He has no legal obligation to Pixie for what happened.
He has no criminal responsibility for what happened. What happened
was an unfortunate and unforeseen event in which he probably
fully regrets and has made attempts to remedy on his own his
actions which were bad and should not have taken place. But did
how did he remedy them? How did he remedy them? He made attempts
to remedy them. How did he attempt to remedy? By asking her,
"Hey, is there anything that I can do? I'm really sorry that
this happened. Is there anything that that I can do to make it
better?
That being which shows that he he fully regrets his actions and
he has shown remorse and made attempts to remedy them on his
own privately. I think I think bringing up the law might be a
bit I mean I think that might be too high level stuff or too
detailed. The law just doesn't apply here. It just is not applicable.
Well, so let's put the law just aside just for a second. Right.
So you agreed what he did was bad, right? Yes, it was bad. Okay.
It was bad. Okay. And you're also saying by implying it's bad
that he knew what he was doing, right? He knew just like you
say Pixie had risk by sending and making
I do not believe that he he had any possible I don't believe
that he understood that this was a possible outcome. I don't
believe that when he shared it he thought it would be seen by
anybody but the people he shared it with. And I don't think he
thought for one second that this was a possible outcome
or he would not think about that if he starts distributing because
we don't know how many people he sent that video to cuz right
now the estimates are over 10 right I no I don't know how many
people he sent the video to but right now the estimates are over
10 which is a lot a lot of people right if you start if you tell
nothing to me estimates mean nothing to me well it's inord give
you it's we know for a fact it's over 10 in the court. Do you
agree or can you give that or do you disagree and want to fight
on that?
I don't know that it matters. What happened was is
that sorry
I Yeah, you can tell. Yeah. And I I'll just one
you don't know you don't think it matters how many people he
sent it to for it to be a risk for it to come out. So if he sent
it to a 100 or if he sent it to his DVG Yes. Absolutely. Absolutely.
Yes. Of course it does. But I don't think that anyone that he
sent it to, he would have done so without the understanding that
or or with the I don't think he would have anyone. I don't think
he would have shared it with anybody. He did not have the belief
that it would be seen only by them. Do you not have you never
you ever heard of like you tell one secret and it gets around
the world or whatever? Like you've never told And it's the same
thing with
to the same thing applies. He should have understood that if
you make this shared. Okay. Can I hold on? Hold on. I need to
No, no, no. I need to ask him a question now, Ry. So, can you
explain to me why Pixie needs to understand that that will be
shared, but Destiny didn't understand that this could possibly
be
publicly there. Those are two different uh barriers of of understanding.
So Pixie understanding that someone besides Destiny or that Destiny
had a reasonably high likelihood of sharing it with at least
one other person being true. As much as Destiny believing with
a reasonable degree of likelihood that this would be leaked by
a third party and used as a weapon against him in the future.
Um, I don't think that those are No, I don't think I don't think
that he was engaging with a reckless her privacy. You think Destiny
could have believed what Pixie should have, which you think Pixie
should have about the third party he sent it to? You think he
should have thought, well, I' I've created this now. I'm sharing
it with them. Actually, it's kind of reasonable that they would
just share it around to whoever. No, I don't think that that's
reasonable at all whatsoever. He's sharing it with one person
in a with in a private conversation, you know, with with
um with without malice, you know, he's not doing so recklessly
or anything like that. You know, arguing had malice.
No, no, I'm not states.
No, I'm just saying that there's there's yes, he knew that there
was a like with anything, he knew there was a risk it would be
seen by a third party, but besides the person he was sharing
it with, but he did not he and I don't even know. You're asking
me to speculate about his mental state. I'm saying that I don't
think he did so that he engaged in this behavior with an understanding
of the con possible consequences as they are today. And I don't
think that if he did think about what could happen and what has
happened, he would have ever done so in the past. I think that
when when he did it, he was doing so thinking that it would be
okay and not really thinking he was doing anything that bad or
in any way violating Pixie's consent in, you know, significant
way because or privacy because he did not identify her as the
other party. He shared it with one person in a private conversation
and you know it was it's not like you know he Pixie is very recognizable
though like she was around but she was around identify her right
but it was obviously Pixie because she was in the video she's
on the streams everyone knows who she was at that point um including
Rose. So, okay. Well, then then it's on Pixie for creating content
where she's easily identifiable and as a known public figure.
I'm sorry. And so is so is Destiny, though. Wait, so you don't
think it's reasonable for Destiny to think that Rose might send
it to a third party and that that third party might send it to
another third third party? No, I don't think that that's reasonable.
No, I don't think that he expected that to happen. And I don't
think that like whether he expected or not, but do you think
that it's more reasonable that Pixie expected Destiny to send
it to other people? Yes, absolutely. Yeah. Someone that she knows
and trusts.
She should have understood there was a high likelihood. Why she
didn't? Because everyone knows that. No, no, no. Everyone knows
that. No one
knows without their permission knows that if you create if you
send out nudes, if you create content with someone that's explicit,
there's a high degree of likelihood that it will be shared without
your consent. Everybody knows that if you send nudes online,
they're going to be online forever. Everybody knows that. I know,
but Destiny literally fits into what you just said. Destiny should
have known these things. Exactly what he said. Maybe. Yeah. And
maybe so. And he that's why it's wrong and that's why what he
did was bad. Okay. But you still you're saying that he shouldn't
have expected a third party to to leak it to someone else. I'm
saying I don't think that he did. I don't think that his that
he did so. Neither did Pixie. Yes, she did. Or she should have.
Why Why should Destiny was a known public figure that uh was
trusted?
Mr. Consent Guy. He did the Bob 7 stuff and covered uh oh my
god I can't believe he would send these things to other people
without their consent. He said all the right words. Yeah. Any
we're getting kind of bogged down. This is just my belief but
no there are different degrees of a very good point. Hold on.
You cut her off. Let her finish. Making a very good point. I
mean what do you have what do you have to say to that? He is
Mr.
Okay. So, Destiny, we uh Pixie and and myself, myself, I don't
even talk to Destiny, but I thought uh because of during that
Bob 7 arc that he was Mr. Consent Guy because when he was covering
all of Bob 7's uh stuff about leaking nudes and whatnot, he he
said all the right things as to why this is wrong. He showed
a full understanding of the consequences of of Bob 7 sending
uh other people's nudes or sharing other people's nudes. He he
fully outlined it during that era. So I think Pixie had a very
strong reason to trust him. Uh like I as a complete stranger
had had the impression that he was trustworthy in that way. So
if I were his friend, why wouldn't I trust him? And she did.
and he violated that trust and there were unfortunate unforeseen
consequences and that really sucks, right? But so why should
she? There's a contradiction there. You can't say he did a bad
thing and then he didn't know what was like obviously you're
saying he did something bad that had risk to other people, right?
You you agree with that. He did something bad that had risks
to other people. Okay, perfect. So he knew those risks going
in because otherwise we would say he did an accident. But it
wasn't an accident, right? I believe it was an accident. I don't
think that he in purposely vi he purposely shared a shared content
with the third party that he knew would be leaked to the public.
I think that happened accidentally on and was done by someone
who was not him against his wishes. And and like I said, I I
think this was a learning experience for him most likely. And
I don't think that he he understood fully that this was a possible
outcome or I don't think he would have done it. But the fact
of the matter is I don't know. Hold on. Can I just ask you really
quickly? Um I'm speculating. So he had the Well, he had the whole
Bob 7 thing. So I feel like he knows that it's a possibility,
right? Other people have done that. They've shared, I guess.
So yes, I guess he knew that it was possible, but he likely did
not think that it would happen. Why? I don't know. Because he
did it. And if he if he had thought that this was a a likely
or even a a remote possible outcome, he wouldn't have done it.
I think that what the people he shared it with, he trusted and
he had had a relationship with enough to where he thought that
he these people were trustworthy with a video that was otherwise
um you know a
uh private matter with no sense of uh you know so Destiny uh
Destiny has said multiple times that he expects his DMs to be
leaked. What do you think of that? Well, then I maybe maybe he
did know that this was a possibility and he did it anyway, in
which case he was acting with recklessly and that'sing stupid
of him and he was and and he was wrong for doing so. Okay. So,
do you think though still that Pixie should have expected him
to leak it? Not expected him to leak it, but would have should
have ex Hold on one second. Not that she should have expected
him to leak it, but that she should have understood that the
behavior that she was engaging in carried a risk that meant him
sharing it with a third party. Now, I'm not talking about it
getting leaked to the entire world. I think that they both were
ignorant to that possibility. But I think that she should have
understood there if by making this by allowing Destiny to film
this content of me sucking his dick, there's a possible like
there's a possibility he will send the video to someone else.
Okay, so imagine imagine uh your Pixie uh and Destiny's Destiny,
but imagine Okay,
do we have to do the analogies? Okay, actually no. Think of this
like it's an unfair advantage using analogies with this guy.
Yes, I'm stupid. I need one second and Okay, let me see. Just
tell me if this is uh a way to do you think this is a fair way
to to look at it. Okay, if you
give uh your house key to a close friend to to housesit while
you are away, do you think that there's a level of trust that
you would have there? Uh that's more than if that person in turn
took your house key and gave it to a stranger like the same.
Do you think that you it's reasonable to expect your friend to
safeguard you uh more so than that friend would expect a a stranger
to uh keep your house safe? I love you, but I refuse to engage
with analogies. So, so not okay. Pixie trusted Destiny because
they had a shared history and and they had a shared friendship.
Yes. Yes. Okay. Destiny did not have that shared history and
friendship with the Rose person. That doesn't exist. We can see
basically all of their DMs. He didn't know this person. They
didn't know anything about identifying them. They had talked
multiple times. They were on a on a and he by the way and he
is sharing something. So Destiny's was already on the internet.
Okay. He's being cavalier cavalier with their shared privacy
to a party she doesn't know or trust at all. It is a clear violation.
Yes, he was. Yeah. And it is not the same violation of her. But
it's not the same either way, right? It's not the same as Pixie
going in handing something, this shared creation that they have
to Destiny and saying, "I trust you." It's not the same as him
taking that shared creation and handing it to another party who
she doesn't know and saying, "I trust you."
That's my entire point. That's my whole point is that it's not
the same. They're different levels of certainty or or they're
different amounts of risk. Yes. And Destiny took the far riskier
option. Yes.
And if that's how your opinion then
your opinion Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. He took the far riskier option.
Yes. Absolutely. Do you think it changes anything that his dick
was already on Kiwi before? I don't think that that's relevant.
No. That he didn't know the consequences. he wouldn't have been
uh very familiar with the potential consequences. Listen, we
know what Destiny knew would be possible consequences. We can't
I was speculating when I said that. I said that because I think
that it lessens his like overall
responsibility and I think that it it it shows that he was not
acting with any sort of intentional malice and that he did so
in what could almost be called good faith but would I'd rather
call it just in disregard for the possible consequences because
he believed this person was trustworthy. He was ex oh this is
what he was extending
uh Pixie's consent and belief of privacy to this Rose person
kind of bringing her into the circle with the understanding that
that that she would in turn hold true to Pixie's consent and
and privacy.
No, that's not a thing that you can I know, but it's it
it kind of happened. It's what I believe happened. I believe
that he thought that it was gonna be okay this I don't know it's
just I just do but no I just think that he a gut feeling you
have right and and but the fact of the matter is based on my
interpretation of the events but the fact there's another really
important question here sorry extreme that is a really important
question here but you understand this is why people call you
a destiny defender right because you won't logically defend why
you're saying things your hunches tend to skew in his direction
that it has a lot to do with you being accused of things that
you feel you were not at all guilty of and you're trying to project
that onto Destiny. And I don't think that's the case with Destiny
at all. And you're seeing it that way despite the overwhelming
evidence suggesting otherwise. And I'd like to use that as a
perfect jumping off point. Extreme Dad. I brought it up earlier
and you said we could talk about No, no, no. Let me respond to
this before you go distracting. Okay. So, go ahead. First of
all, yes, you're right. And that I
see
some similarities between what happened to me and what happened
to him. The fact of the matter, can you give us the quote again?
the quote, the Discord quote that you used. What are you talking
about? The chair thing. The thing you said in Discord that Stop.
Shut up. We'll get there if you really really want to. Let me
talk. So, um I think that there are some similarities and yes,
I do feel a sense of of um empathy for what's going on right
now because at the end of the day,
um
people what happened to me was wrong and it was not factually
accurate and what Vosch did was evil and cruel. But people don't
know what you're talking about. Yeah, we have people tell us
what happened. People didn't really care because I was seen as
the enemy. I was at the time conservativele leaning and I people
then thought, okay, he's a bad person and there you would in
the world so they would have to sit on your face. That's what
I let me speak. And so there's there was this sense of oh, he's
a bad guy, which I am, but you know, so there's this sense of
we can do whatever we want to him. We can lie about him. We can
um say whatever we want. And I think you are kind of doing that.
I think that you're acting maliciously. And I think that you're
overegging the pudding. And I think at the end of the day, you
will stick to this story that he is legally responsible and he's
going to go to jail and he's going to be pick. By the way, don't
say that. Don't say that. We have a $500 bet on whether or not
he'll be charged with a crime. I I think I believed he would
be charged at the time. I have no I I would say like I'd still
lean in that direction. You can just pay me my money.
Why? Cuz I deserve it. Why would you? You can get it when you
win the bet. What are you talking about? That's so long from
now. I mean, I'm broke now. I'm here right now. I mean, he's
honest.
I have $3. Okay. Okay. And you know I'm going to win. You know
I'm going to win. Okay. Before we get to the money, we did agree.
You did respond. Yes. Okay. Do you do think he's going to go
to jail or be charged with a crime? I think that he will be charged.
Yes. I don't know if he'll go to jail. I don't know what the
evidence is like. I I do think he'll be charged.
And that is just like I see you're just saying that because Hold
on. Wait. Do Why do you think I think that? Because it makes
him seem like uh like it makes him seem bad because it makes
you can use that. I can just give you evidence that we all know
to be true. The person who's accusing him. Give me you can give
me evidence that he's going to be charged with a crime. The person
accusing him accuses him of wiretapping. Okay. Accuses him of
recording without
Ludicrous and absurd which is a felony which is a felony in the
state of Florida. Okay. And he has admitted multiple times on
his stream to committing that felony. Show me president. Show
me president. Show me another case where an individual was charged
with a felony wiretapping charge as the result of a private conversation
over the internet or or anything even closely resembling what's
going on here. Show me a case previously that has been charged
and I will surely you'll be able to provide also one that supports
your side as well. If you're asking for a case from us, you have
a case that proves your side. No, my the what proves my zero
precedent for this happening at all whatsoever. You cannot find
one case that even closely resembles this in the legal system
the world over.
Wiretapping. Wiretapping is not relevant to this. Wiretapping
is not what happened here. That is so asinine. Yeah, I know.
But isn't that in relation to what he did to Cherry? That is
not being disputed here. Okay. So, what do you just, you know,
for the record, what do you think about what he did? Nobody,
nobody has any idea what happened to Cherry. And from what I
understand, what is alleged
is that he recorded her in person, right? Yes. He recorded her
wiretapping then. I I know. So, I don't I don't know why we were
talking about wiretapping. Um
Well, because I I'm saying that I think that's what I think he's
going to be charged with.
Yeah. And we all know that he's not. And I just think that, you
know, I mean, listen, it's a little it's a little rough, but
here, are there presidential rulings for wiretapping the state
of Florida based on someone secretly recording a private conversation?
Yes, Florida has strong precedents regarding wiretapping and
secret recordings under its two-party consent law. This law makes
it illegal to intercept or record a private conversation without
the consent of all parties involved, with some exceptions. The
exceptions are law enforcement with a warrant, public settings
where there's no expectation of privacy, and threatening or criminal
conduct being recorded for law enforcement purposes, i.e. someone
recording a crime in progress. Now, I would say with basically
the recordings that we've seen on the internet so far, none of
these seem to be the case. With his descriptions of the Lauren
de Laguna stuff, that also seems to not be the case. He's using
it to win social arguments. He has bragged about violating this
law repeatedly on his stream. He has said, "I don't care about
the penalties. Charge me. I'll pay the fines. my public reputation
and my private reputation is way more important to me than the
law. I believe that given these statements that it's a good idea
to charge this person who says I'm going to keep violating this
law over and over and over again. Do you disagree? I don't know.
Uh what are you asking if I disagree with exactly?
If somebody is if somebody is accused of violating a law and
they have bragged multiple times about how they violate this
law constantly because they care way more about their own private
rep their own reputation when they've bragged publicly about
winning private disagreements with their friends using these
recordings. When friends are public on the record saying they've
left this friend group because he privately records single party
consent with sorry without without all parties consents. He privately
records these conversations. This is the law. This is the same
law for recordings as well. There's an escalator for recordings,
but it's the same law for recordings. He has broken this law
multiple times. He's bragged about breaking this law multiple
times. I think it is incumbent on the state of Florida to charge
him before he continues to break this law over and over again.
Do you disagree? I smoked I smoked fentinel on your stream last
time because I disagree. Yeah, you can brag about breaking the
law all you want. You can even have video evidence of you breaken.
You can even break the law. But the fact of the matter is, it's
not about what you do. It's about what can be proved in court.
Okay. I
go ahead. Go ahead. Sorry. You just talked about the fact of
the matter is that kind of gives us a judge in the country. There's
not a jury of our crimes. There's not a world that will pick
up this case and you know
Extreme dad. I need I need your attention. So you'd mentioned
the fent, right? Uh I also want to argue the perfect segue. The
perfect segue. Absolutely. Well, you've done this three times
and you did say you waited patiently. Go ahead. You did say I
could I could talk about this. You waited patiently. Go ahead.
Have your time this the crimes that I think that line up with
destinies that kind of parallel to you and it's not it's not
a hypothetical cuz this happened, right? I believe there was
a what happened is is being disputed, I think. Right. Absolutely.
So, from what I remember, there was some form of a care package
with cash and drugs and somehow you had some sort of roll in
distribution and then it ended with one of the parties passing
away. Is that right? That is absolutely incorrect. Um, on all
on all each of those uh points is incorrect. First of all, the
quote unquote care package contained $300 cash. That's it. Second
of all, I was not involved in the quote unquote distribution
as I was, you know, in a different state at the time of it happening.
Um, and had been for several days. And third, um, I think that
pretty much covers it actually. And third, uh, I didn't do anything.
Then why does Lav call you a murderer? Because Lav does anything
for attention. She's aing strung out drug user herself with [__]
who
whose arms apparently are so scratchy and itchy that she has
to like cover them up on stream. Who knows why, you know, but
allegedly allegedly I've never heard this before. I saw it happen
with in her stream with Andrew, but that's beside the point.
Lav said what she said be because she does anything for attention.
Lav also had asked me to Phillip so that she could get him arrested
for
uh dating a 16-year-old while I was there.
What Philip did,
Philip is responsible for to try and say that I am responsible
for his death would be saying that because I I had some money
sent there and he chose to steal it and buy drugs that he overdosed
with, that makes me liable for his death. is the same as saying
Destiny's liable for theing leaks of Pixie's nudes.
You never touched drugs at the time. You weren't involved in
drugs. I was and have used drugs as I displayed yesterday on
stream or or on Friday on stream. Yes, I have. I was using drugs
at the time. I used drugs today. I'm a drug user. Yes. However,
I have not ever in my entire life distributed drugs to anyone
else, sold drugs for profit, or in any way engaged in behavior
that could be identified as a reckless disregard for anyone's
safety when it comes to drug use. I did not use drugs around
Philip or the other person. I did not use drugs. So, you were
just two independent drug users who definitely never shared drugs
or used drugs together. Absolutely correct. We did not share
drugs. I did not use drugs in his home. I did not use drugs around
him. He never saw me using drugs and I have never shared my drugs
with anyone in my entire life. I use drugs personally and my
drugs are for me exclusively and that's just the facts. So he
got very very careful. Yes, he got money from me by stealing
it and planning an elaborate ruse in You said you gave him the
money. No, I never said that. He planned this elaborate ruse
knowing that my money knowing that I had a package coming the
next day or not the next day but but in a few days. He asked
his dad to come over and make it seem like he was kicking us
out for partying. And the other person who was involved, our
friend
made like started crying, begging me to take him home, you know,
6 hours away. And as so I ended up having to leave. We got kicked
out by Philip's dad, which he planned. And then our friend made
me take him home to Virginia 6 hours away. And then Philillip
started bragging about, you know, that he was going to steal
my money and buy drugs with it. And I asked him about it. I said,
"Philip, is did you say that?" And he said, "No, I can't believe
you would even accuse me of that. I swear I'm going to send it
to you as soon as it gets here. I'm gonna send it to you. Like,
I promise, bro. How could you even think that? How did he know
there was money in there? Um I've like I don't know exactly.
I don't know if he he just knew there was money in a random package.
No, I don't know. He was creating a clever ruse. So he had to
know ahead of time. He knew that I was getting a package. I asked
him, "Hey, Phillip, can I get a package sent here?" And I, you
know, obviously was broke and and maybe I I don't remember exactly
if I had mentioned the money that it was going to be money that
was coming. But so by by somehow mentioning and sending that
package to that house, there was a risk involved that you were
aware of. And I am I do have some responsibility in what took
place. Of course. Yeah. So you did a bad thing. I did do a bad
thing. Yes. Absolutely.
Fair enough. There's respons and there's blame. There's blame
to be placed on me. there. I had responsibility and I I totally
failed
uh both Philip and his dad in that situation and engaged in behavior
that was naive and reckless and wrong. And I feel bad about it.
I really do. Um I feel bad about what happened and I I think
it's really unfortunate. But at the end of the day, Philillip
made his own decisions and unfortunately those decisions which
he knew were irresponsible and reckless at the time resulted
in his death and and that sucks. But well, don't feel bad. You
didn't do anything wrong, right? I already said that. I I just
got done saying exact opposite. But it's not my fault that he
stole from me and used that money that to buy drugs and then
overdose on them. His death, his overdose is not my responsibility.
He stole from me, lied to me, and said that. Actually, pull these
up on stream really quick because these are these are just crazy.
Look at this. Oh [__] You're telling me that logs?
We got logs, bro. And they're just they're they're something
else, man. Oh my god. Well, I'll send them. Can we get some music
going for the while he's doing that? I know. Something to [__]
take up the some vibes. Let's go. And I assume Lab isn't around
to if she wants to, you know. Lab would just put up the signal.
Let's see if she's around. Oh, it's wrong. Wrong one. Wrong one.
Wrong one.
No, that is perfect.
I don't know why that came through multiple times, but cool.
Oh my god, it's so loud. It is very loud. Jesus Christ. Oh, Jesus
Christ. But that is the correct signal. Oh boy. Okay, I'm waiting
on these logs. I got an MD right now. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And was
around earlier. I don't know if she's watching or if she's going
to hop on. So, well, and this is all Lav's fault. Like, Lav is
the one who is responsible for for making his death into something
of a spectacle for and making his death into content. Like, it's
it's sad what happened. And I I regret that it, you know, I regret
having ever, you know, gone there, having sent money there. I
just didn't understand at the time the situation I was in and
it had unfortunate consequences. But again, just like with Destiny,
I didn't fully grasp the situation. I didn't fully understand
the risk I was taking and I caused someone to be able to purchase
drugs and overdose and die. But that's not my fault. And I there's
nothing anyone can do about it legally or criminally. It's just
a shitty thing that happened
and it really sucks and there's nothing anyone can do about that
other than tell me that I'm bad for being a It's okay. We could
just blame Lav as you said, right? And she can defend herself.
You can blame me for being a low-life piece of [__]
drug user if you want and for having engaged in behavior that
was naive and stupid and and reck and
I would agree with you on all sides. One second. I I'll put him
up in just a second. just goes fiddling with an emote. Uh, no,
I'm I'm trying to get I'm messaging or I'm adding lav and just
saying, but yeah, I mean, just like with Destiny, like my my
actions had consequences, but those consequences are not legally
enforcable or Yeah. Uh, that's just not true. They're they're
not really the same, but I'm going to pull this up. I assume
it's all fine to pull this up. Yes. Yeah. Okay. All right. Okay.
Phillip, August 15th, 2023.
Hey, I just woke up. What's up? Why has everyone been telling
me you're feigning? Figning to steal planning maybe to steal
my stuff. Phillip, have you been bragging about doing that? No,
man. What the [__] Who has been telling you that?
It didn't come yet, by the way. I just checked. The only thing
I can say think I told I told Gracious the situation and he made
it just a joke about it. But that channel was just me and Gracious.
Phillip, I know you asked your dad to do that. I think you did
so to try to steal from me. Please reconsider.
This is not what happened at all, dude. I'm asking you this is
your friend. Genuinely pretty offended. You would assume this.
Well, I don't know who told you this story because Gracious joked
about it with me after I told him. But then I told him, "Nah,
for real. I'm going to mail him all of it." It wasn't him. I
don't know who who that even is. You know what, Phillips? I believe
you. I do. I'm going to choose to believe you because I want
you to be telling the truth. It's like the Desty situation. I
promise I will mail you your package. And again, I'm very sorry
about what happened with my dad. I should have been more open
about how much of a hard ass he can be. Okay. What does his dad
do? What is going on? His his dad is the one who came and made
us leave. He kicked us out the day before my money got there.
Okay. Interesting. So, his dad was in on the ruse. He wasn't
necessarily in on the ruse, but Philip had asked him to pretend
like he was uh mad at us for partying and that we had to leave.
Philip asked him to I thought you guys weren't doing drugs together.
They were drinking and partying and I was uh otherwise I have
already uh asked and
Okay, sounds I'm just saying like I don't want to rehash what
I've already
admitted that can I ask what this was supposed to prove. What
What were we proving with these logs?
That dead guy. he is responsible for his own behavior that he
chose to lie, cheat, and steal from someone he claimed it was
his friend and then bought drugs with what money that I needed
and that belonged to me and then he overdosed and died on them.
And you're saying that that makes me responsible for his death?
Look at those messages and tell me I'm responsible.
Um, what uh I would say did you know this guy was a like he's
an an addict when you sent him the money? I'm not going to say
you're responsible no matter what. I didn't send him the money.
The money was sent to me in a package that was addressed to me
that he had to steal. Yes. I asked him if I could have a package
sent there and he said yes. Okay. And he had to steal that. Yes.
It was addressed to me and I had a package delivered to his house.
And yeah, there is some responsibility on me for that, but not
for his death. And you can know it was not drugs sent because
his dad obviously got the package and we obviously have complied
with I've complied with a police investigation into this matter.
And if there were drugs in that package, I would be in jail right
now. Well, not if you did them all, right? Yeah. Yes. If there
were drugs in the [__] package, I obviously would
have been in jail. But you did do in jail though, right? Was
this for a different thing? Was it for the Discord thing? Yeah.
Yes. Prison actually. But not unlike Tom Foolery. I've actually
been there.
Holy [__] Tom Fooly catching strays
base. Uh well, I think does anyone else have questions? Uh well,
I mean,
can you change the title of your video? Oh, yeah. Let's talk
about that. So, you came on Queman stream earlier today and you
didn't like that Queman called you a Destiny Defender.
You know, my video title calls you a file. That's fine. Um, as
long as
Yeah, as long as Destiny Defender isn't in there, I don't care.
Okay. I mean, it is kind of work. What if you're actively defending
Destiny though? Like, I feel like you're Destiny. I'm disputing
the legality of the actions. Yeah. You You're literally refusing
to look at the law when I point out that like all elements are
met. No, you're wrong. You're you're literally you're lally guilty
of something if your conduct meets all elements and by by the
like on the face by what is in the public, Destiny is guilty
under that federal statute or guilty or whatever you want to
put it by. It doesn't matter what happens in the court of public
opinion. It matters what happens in a court of law. In order
for him to be guilty of a crime, you'd have to find a district
attorney to press it to charge a case and you'd have to find
an agency to go out and arrest. I said liable because it's a
civil case. I said found liable. Extreme dead. You I thought
you thought it was criminal. It was Is it criminal or not? Can
I have my money or not? No. Uh pick No. Pixie thing was never
what I was betting on. Or a criminal. Oh, you're betting on the
cherry thing, huh? Uh yep. I have to wait not this birthday,
but next birthday for her. Can we just make it 2025, please?
Please. I feel like he's bartering. Two months. Three months.
I just have one question. It sounds like I'll give you I'll give
you 20 bucks if you uh if you want to get out of it. I'll give
you 20 bucks. How about you give me 250 right now and we call
it square and I'll pay you back if I
give me at least half. I'll give you 20 bucks. Half of 20? No,
I'll just wait for the How about you for 20 bucks? I feel like
it's like 51.49 right now, but I I'll give you 20 bucks. No,
it's 100% 0%. So, I'll just wait.
just go over like a dollar a day for like the next two weeks
so he sticks around. Um, no. Um, just kidding. What I should
be getting paid for is this awesome content. Yeah. Well, so before
we get to that, you're getting you're getting more viewers right
now than you've gotten all week. Come on. Uh, that is true. But
it's also been a Destiny night, so those always bring in viewers.
Okay, that's an extreme. I technically had higher viewers before
you came on. I was just I didn't I didn't know I haven't even
looked at your viewers at all whatsoever. I I I'm just kidding
and I'm happy to be here and I appreciate you having me on.
Can we ask you so one last thing on one last thing? Extreme dad.
You were talking about there's like uh so if we fight on the
pixie stuff as whether that makes him malicious, right? But earlier
you'd mentioned also that lab wanted you to dock someone which
was also bad. So we would probably agree that bad, right? Yeah.
bad. Okay. So, if we can put in a box all the things Destiny's
done over 10 people over the last 5 years, including people on
this call and I are not friends. Hold on. I am not I don't like
him. You think he's bad person? I think he's a bad person. Yeah.
Reckless and bad. Okay. Reckless and bad argument over then.
And on top of that, he had a [__] rapist responsibility.
had a responsibility to me
and he failed me and he failed me and he came and he the it criminal.
No, no, no. He's none of those things. He's not criminal at all.
Defender. No, no, no. But the fact of the matter is that
predator.
No, he did not act predatory in any way whatsoever.
That is ridiculous. Dead would have to like him. This is why
a habitual consent violator is the best. Nobody can deny it.
You You do agree. Habitual consent violator, right? Habitual
consent violator. Yeah, sure. Habitual consent violator. Consent
obviously doesn't matter very much to him. Like if you had had
a daughter, you would say stay away from that guy, right?
Consent. Again, I I I ask what was he supposed to do? Say, "Hey,
Pixie, I have this 19-year-old Discord kitten that I goon out
with all the time, and I want to share our video of you sucking
my dick to her. Is are you cool with that?" Yeah, because he
knows she would say no.
If he knows that she would say no, then he's doing it against
her will and he knows that. Yeah, that's like the implied thing
with ally. Anything you take with like a significant other, you
guys break up. It's like it's understood that you won't send
that unless there's some sort of understanding that you're kind
of cool with that, right? But it was not after a breakup or anything
like that. It was not done like after I'm I'm saying basically
it wasn't with somebody and he knew she didn't want him to do
that but he did it anyway. Right. I think that he
probably I think that he probably assumed that if she understood
the situation as it was that she would be okay with it and that
he but he didn't ask because but he didn't ask to clarify because
nobody would because that'd be weird as as a thing to do and
nobody ever does that. Be weird to ask for consent. That would
be so weird. Why would it be weird?
Nobody does that. Do you mind if I Do you mind? What do you mean
nobody does that? Nobody sends like this to strangers to random
19-year-old hopefully e girls. Yes, they do. People share content
they're not supposed to all the time privately. Yeah. Something
your experience with. Have you ever done that extreme death?
Personally, no. But then again, I don't get a lot of nudes. Okay.
So, you would Well, this stream's turning that around. So, I
wouldn't I wouldn't and I haven't. And I think that it's wrong
and it's bad that he did it and he should like apologize and
try to uh make amends if he can or or try to um make it right
if he can which he has done and that is the extent to which what
do you mean he has he anything can happen. He has asked her if
there's anything that he can do and if they come to an agreement
like privately then that is the extent to which this can be enforced
legally, criminally or uh publicly you know there's nothing else
that can be done. Yes, I do. Absolutely. Why? He doesn't seem
like a man who is remorseful.
Well, look how you guys are treating him. Look at what you guys
are saying about him. Look at what's happened. Of course he has
to save face where he can where he threatened to Queen and just
Yeah. And I'm right right about there with him. Trust me, we
can do it together. Damn.
Drugs, bro. Who do you think you can take? Uh, Jtock, do you
think you can take Destiny or me in a one-on-one death? I don't
know about you.
I don't know. I don't know. Yeah, bro. I'm 6'4, 225 lbs. I mean,
you're bigger than me, so that seems concerning right off the
bat. Hey, listen. I always tell people I will fight anyone, anyone
in the world, provided they're both smaller and weaker than I
am. Do you mind if I ask him a political question since we're
kind of wrapping up this part? Go ahead. Uh, sure. Go ahead.
I was just curious if we could I know Extreme Dad has made a
defense of the tariffs. I don't want to totally like if you don't
want to go
that Hold on. I have one more question on the on the Pixie thing.
Do you think um do you think Destiny once Pixie was messaging
him so Lav leaked that Pixie and Destiny had slept together,
right? because Destiny probably told her and basically Pixie
freaked the [__] out was like how the could laugh
possibly know this like there's no way somebody else knows about
us have having together. You think it was incumbent on Desty
to share then that he had shared of her non-consensually with
other people when she was clearly freaking out when it became
evident that he did not have consent that she was very upset
about it that other people might know about their relationship
in any way? No, because I think he thought he was going to get
away with it. Okay.
Sorry. Like I we could we could go into that obligated to. Yeah,
he should have done it, but I don't think he did it. But I think
that he didn't because he thought he was going to get away with
it. Yeah, people tend to think do things that they think they
can get away with. If you don't think you can get away with it,
you don't usually do that. Which is exactly why this happened.
He thought he could get away with it. He didn't think that anything
would happen. And so he thought that he was doing something that
was not in violation of Pixie's consent or privacy. He thought
that it would be okay. And because of a freak turn of events
by some and an unidentified third party, it became an issue that
uh sucks for Pixie. And I feel sympathy for her. But the fact
of the matter is there's nothing that anyone can do about it.
And you guys need to admit that or come to terms with that because
it's true. There's not aing court in the country that's going
to hear this case. There's not a jury of our peers that will
find him guilty. Literally a court currently hearing this civil
case. Like there there's literally there's literally a court
hearing that case is the US district court.
Filing is not the same as uh you know a trial. Bro, you're talking
about a trial. Yeah, they're on they've already both agreed to
a trial.
And we'll see how that doesn't mean it can't be dismissed, but
like they've already both agreed to a trial. They're going to
have to show significant proof proof of like some malfeasants
to not go there, right? Which I believe there will be, but I
don't think it'll go to trial. And if it does, he will not be
found guilty or liable. He won't have to pay a dime. And that's
exactly how it should be. They have a date, though. And you So,
here's the thing. Extreme Dad did Extreme Dad, I don't think,
knows this. I said there's one out for Destiny and it's if um
if they can't substantiate any of that video being shared I think
past um and they'll they'll have to have this ar they'll have
to have another argument but basically if the video was shared
in April before the law took effect and they rule they're going
to set the precedent that continuing to publish something so
long as you did it a long time ago you're no longer liable after
that like even though you could take it down you have the power
to take it down and you don't that that doesn't matter he's not
the one who shared it then they can then they can show that doesn't
matter under the law but I' we've already gone through the law
he has no ability
responsibility and that's fine but don't interrupt me while I'm
explaining. So basically he is even though he has the ability
to take it down that ability to take it down doesn't mean he's
continued to publish it. If they ruled that and they set that
precedent which I don't believe they will but they might then
he would they would be dismissed because he wouldn't be like
liable if they couldn't produce evidence showing he'd sent it
after. How is he supposed to take down a video in any meaningful
sense? Uh he would no longer be publishing it. So if if it is
true the one publishing the video
yes he is by sending it to somebody else you are making it available
that is another so the word I believe is no you are not distribute
yeah don't understand the law and you can't fathom the law and
it's like crazy you can't take it down by by you don't think
he had deleted the videos already like he can't take it down
so he continued the the whole point is he had the video available
to the other person up until November right he did yeah okay
yeah so disclose means to transfer, publish, distribute, or make
accessible. He had made that video accessible to that person
up until November. Then a third party grabbed it because he had
continued to make it accessible. If they argue that because he
originally published it in April, that he's not liable for making
it accessible up until November. If they argued that and they
set that precedent, then he would have an out. Then if they couldn't
produce another piece of evidence of him sharing that same video
to another person, then I think he they could get it dismissed.
But that is the only way they get it dismissed. Otherwise, he's
like dead to rights on every element of this charge uh of this
uh I guess. Do we know what date it will be in? 2026, but it's
not criminal. Don't worry. This won't be the one he's charged
under. Date date. Florida. It's in the It's in the US District
Court for the Southern District of Florida. USDC, Southern Florida.
May 2026 is goes to trial. And what does the jury determine,
Jtock? What does the jury determine? Again, depending on if um
depending whether or not he get if they if they basically determine
that he made this accessible after the date. If they say he continued
to disclose they determined okay I'm giving you a conditional
if they determine he disclosed that based on sending it to Rose
and he continue to disclose it until November then he will be
found liable for this and then they'll determine damages and
what he's being charged with like exactly how much money it would
cost. Yes. Liability and damages. That's all that a jury can
decide. Sure. You understand there are damages beyond one's harm
to income, right? that there are like emotional damages and she's
seeking emotional damages just from the video being published
but from him and his conduct afterwards, right? She can seek
uh you know a pony and and and uh and you know I'm just
think accept the case if she didn't have like they they would
say no no this is like totally invalid if she had no claim. That's
going to happen. Just wait. There's still time. Okay. I so I
would bet you on this that it won't be dismissed unless they
can say unless they decide uh that it was not made accessible
based on it still being available in November. Well, I I'll uh
that's a little bit too uh high. Yeah, you don't understand it.
Yeah, I'm I'll admit that that's above my understanding, but
I will keep my you know fail to be charged by July 1st, 2026
$500 bet. Okay. I mean, if he's found liable in this case before
then, would you count that? No, absolutely not. I wouldn't count
that. Who do you think I am? An idiot? I'm already giving you
f favorable enough conditions. Just a charge. Like, not even
arrested. Not even not even um found guilty. Just a charge. That's
favorable enough. Okay. I hear Lab's going to come in. It's going
to become a real [__] show here in a second. Uh possibly.
Is she coming in? Hold on. I'm going to grab a soda. I'll be
right back. Do we have Do we have contact? She got me excited
for nothing. Let's go.
She doesn't have perms. So, if I give her perms, does that imply
she'll join? Ah, let's go, guys. Guys, I'm going to dip because
probably going to say slurs.
We love uh you don't know that for sure, but also she's on Twitch.
She's on Twitch. Oh, okay. Well, yeah. Okay. Thank you. Appreciate
it. Yeah, no problem. Thanks for coming on. As long as there
are no F slurs, T slurs, N
It wouldn't promise that. Lives mic keeps turning on, but I can't
hear her at all. That stuff is fine. Oh, I have her turned to
zero volume. Oh, whoops. Jesus, bro. That's so disrespectful.
I'm back. Queen, I got her back on. Sorry. Hold on.
My Discord isn't working. Hold on. I'll I need to restart. Okay.
Bye-bye. What' you say? I missed it. Thanks for hanging out,
Eeko. Thanks for coming on. Are you Thank you. I go bye. See
you. Wait, where's the thing? Appreciate you as always. Leave.
Hold on. Hold on a second. It's still not No, I got it. Bye.
Hey. See you. Maybe this has got to be an operator error. Probably.
Um, can you hear me? Do you think Jesus Christ? Yep. I think
your life is an operator operator error. Lav,
right? Um, I heard that you were saying that I am a heroin and
a crack addict. I'm I I said you're a drug user yourself. I'm
kidding though. But you get to take shots at me. I get to take
shots at you. I think we can both handle it, right? But you actually
I the things I've said about you are true. No, they aren't. And
you know that. You know that
deal drugs to him. You know that. And that's been proven.
You sent drugs. I did not or I would
Oh, so the story's changed again. No, it's you keep you are the
only person told the story about drugs before. You are the only
person who has ever said that it was fentinel that was sent to
the house. You solely are responsible for that lie. You okay?
You are wickedly. The fact that you think I'm Okay, I will pull
up our messages right now. You know what? I can prove it. I can
prove I don't know if I I think that we've brought this up on
stream before. I can prove it. Yeah. And we have this out and
you've been proven wrong, but you continue to tell the lie. You
literally haven't been proven wrong. My friend is dead
before your friend. Your friend that you were asking me to so
you could have him sent to jail for dating a minor. Your friend
Philip that you wanted me to to you so you could call the cops
on him. Yes. Our friend who was in the Discord. He's not a close
friend. He was not my best friend. No, you didn't like him at
all, actually. Yeah, because he was Yeah, I don't want him dead.
Me neither. Did you just say my friend is dead because of you
as if you were morally outraged and now you're like, "Yeah, I
didn't really like him that much." Yeah, he's kind of friend.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I think you're allowed to be morally outraged
when someone kills someone even if you don't like them. No. No,
sir. But I wouldn't go, he was my friend. Right. Right. Right.
Right. Actually, no, you're not. No, he was a friend. He was
someone he was someone who I who I hung out with every day.
But whatever. Yes. What was your literally every single day?
What was your Discord username back then?
Uh
be I think the account's gone though. It can't be gone. Gone.
I think it's gone. I don't know. I'll find it. Keep going. Um
yeah, the I you're JSTLK. I know that you're coming at me right
now in a more hostile tone because I've made fun of you for being
fat and ugly publicly after your became public. And I'm sorry.
Um, but cool to talk about on
stream, right? Stream. Um,
right. But it is very clear that you can be morally outraged
about a a preventable death. Um, even if it wasn't your close
friend. Extreme dad took advantage of someone with like I don't
know what he has. I think it's autism bright conference. He's
still in rehab, I think. I think he just went back to rehab.
This is two years later. Aren't you autistic, Lev? Oh yeah. And
I've never done I've never done done drugs. Yes, you have. You
liar. No, I didn't. You did meth Billy Eyelish's party. No, I
didn't. You are so stupid. And you abuse And you abuse your clonopin.
And you have done drugs. Come on. No, I don't. I don't know why
you're making these things up about me. I thought you were doing
coke at Billy Eyelish's party. Extreme dead. You said something
about her heart. You obviously know that I have not. No, I would
never. Why was your heart reacting the way that it was? Huh?
Oh my god. This is You didn't do any drugs. You didn't do any
drugs at party. I have a I have a heart uh uh congenital heart
defect. If I would have done drugs at any moment, any stimulants
at any moment, I would have had the heart attack that I had.
In what world am I in what world am I going to start doing cocaine
at a Billy Eyish album release party? That's the first time I
heart incident that you had and you had to go to hospital. the
first time I do it. I don't know. You had to go to the hospital
for some reason.
Yeah. Which was It's not because I was doing Coke. What was it
then? It's because my It's because my potassium was at 2.1. It's
because I was severely dehydrated.
And it's because there was an amphetamine in my system. That
could have been from cough medicine. Could have been from a vape.
It could have been from getting my drink drugs. It could her
brother of like drugging your drink or something. Isn't that
why you had a huge fall? No. No.
I did not have a falling out with her. I didn't have a falling
out. This is all Oh my god. This is insane. There was no falling
out. I never accused Phineas of drugging me. I don't know where
the [__] this is coming from. It's like a game of
telephone. Wait, I have heard this. Did somebody just make this
up? Am I
Was this not like something that was said broadly? This is No,
this is a game. This is a full game of telephone. I went on TikTok
and said, "It's weird how Phineas has not reached out to me after
I was in the hospital for a week after this because we were friends."
I got drugged and he hasn't even said anything. No, he Yeah,
how my friend hasn't reached out to me after I got drugged at
his party. That's weird. So, you did get drugged. I was I had
no idea. I had no idea what happened. You just said you got drugged
at the party. So, but I but I have no proof of getting drugged
at the party. So, it could have been anamine. It could have been
a cough medicine that I was taking because I was getting over
a respiratory infection. It could have been something inside
of a jewel. By that she means pseudafed. No, it's not necessarily
not necessarily donate to your GoFundMe before or after your
TikTok. After. Okay. Yeah. And he said, "Yeah, I'm so and he
said, "Yeah, I'm so sorry. I was scared to reach out. I didn't
know what to do." And it was like a completely fine moment and
we are still friends. There's like no no bad blood. Okay. So,
you've never done drugs before. You're just thating morally righteous.
I have never done a drug in my life. I've never been drunk in
my life. You do. You do do controlled substances though. Good
for you. I do what? Controlled substances like colonopen, right?
I have I have
what we say in high school. Hold on one second. I just have to
do some drugs really quick. I have I diagnosed panic disorder.
I take 0.05 0 5 mg maybe once every 3 weeks if I'm going out
to like an excursion. Yes. Hold on one second. Very clearly you
were very clearly Shut up. You were very clearly barred out on
occasion.
I've never been a very tiny girl. Well, that's what it would
be called, right? On.5 mg. No, I've never been barred out.
70 lb. You abuse it. 70 lb. No, I don't abuse it.
No, I was dependent on it. I'm not even saying I'm not even saying
you were abusing it. I was I was dependent on it. I'm saying
that for the record. I'm saying that two two years ago I was
taking 0.25 milligrams every day when I was agorophobic and I
was dependent on it. Oh, you are not agorophobic. Still with
that lie. Come on. I come off it. Laugh. Can you tell the truth
once? I was obviously. How about the
Sorry. Stolen valor. I was never in. It was just for what it's
worth. For what it's worth, I consider you not necessarily a
friend, but there's no bad blood between us on my end. Like I
don't There's obviously bad blood. I have accused you of killing
someone. But it's fine. Like I I just I know that you don't actually
believe that. Fine. Not even a rough day for extreme. No, you're
like you're you're like a you're like a loser. You're like a
you're you you sell drugs to people again. Another I have never
sold drugs in my entire life to anyone ever. You're actually
lying. You're actually lying. And there's actually I can bring
up I can bring in four different people who have heard you say
that you sell drugs and know I would love you to do that then
because that is not the case. Okay. Okay. I want you guys to
do your civic duty and sub to the stream. Give to the stream.
Another person who who else is there is war
chat. I'll answer your questions. what those people say or what
I have said. I don't deal drugs. I'm not a drug dealer. Then
you were lying and now you're telling the truth. No, I don't
even know what then I was saying. I have no idea what you're
talking about, but the fact of the matter is is I don't deal
drugs. I'm not a drug dealer. You are. Okay, you are lying. And
also, I don't know why you admit publicly to this, but I like
it doesn't it's it doesn't behoove you to admit this publicly,
so I I don't even care. I have admitted publicly
obviously for anyone who for anyone who knows me they know that
I am literally scared to take like a Tylenol extra strength.
I have never done a drug. I don't think that that makes me morally
righteous. I've done plenty of cruel things.
I have my vices. They're not
If you take Quonopin every day, it'd be really to be scared of
taking Tylenol.
I don't think that that's true because Tylenol can get worse
than clonopin. If you take Tylenol every day, you're like, what
is it? Your liver. You're not going to crash your car driving
on Tylenol. You're not going to crash your car taking 0.25 milligrams
of colonopin [__] It's not the quantity, right? We're
just talking about the drug. Yes, it is. It's the what? Yes,
it's the it's the it's the dosage. I take I take 10 Tylenol.
Okay. I take five Tylenol. I'm not going to crash my car, right?
But I take two colonopin. I will probably not be able to see
straight. Yeah. So, that's that's a dosage thing. And yes. saying
Tylenol,
you would absolutely not be able to see straight. Are you stupid?
That's why I adjusted it to five. Are you deaf? Okay. So, okay.
So, so you are admitting that it's dosage. I'm just giving you
what would be a like there's no amount unless you take the overdose.
Yes, there is an amount. Well, 10 is not an overdose. You can't
die. I'm saying if you're not talking about overdosing, right?
If we're talking about just talking if you're not talking about
abusing colonopen, you're already cutting in half. What is So
you're cutting in half what is already a prescribed amount, right?
So you're not even taking what's prescribed. So I'm just talking
about No, I am taking what's prescribed.
Oh, you're So you're cutting in half what is prescribed. I am
taking I am taking what is prescribed to me. Right. Okay. But
we would say that those I'm cutting in half a the smallest dose.
Yes. Right. They're controlled substances that can affect your
ability to like, you know, act and move through the world and
operate machinery. Yes. And so can Tylenol if you take too much
of it. Yes. You Oh, we're playing this game. Okay. That's what
They can both you if you take enough of them. Yes. And they can
both make you high if you take enough of them. Yes. Tylenol can't
make you high. Yes, it can. If you take 10 Tylenol, you will
feel No, you don't do drugs. No, you will not. Yes. Well, I don't
I don't think I need to uh be in the field doing research to
know what happens when you take too much of a drug. Apparently,
you do. Yeah, you're I I have no way of knowing if jumping off
of a 10story building could break both of my legs unless analogy
I hate
because you're be that as it may analogy. Anyway, I really just
came on here to say that I'm doing for the first time on my only
fans and my friend is me with his huge disorder.
I'm rehab when I was 14 years old because I I thought you went
I thought you went to rehab way after. I thought you went to
rehab like after the whole you went to Chudlo Logic stream and
then you had to get off Clonopin, right? I that was when I was
physically dependent
Clonopen and No, I did not go to rehab.
Okay. I just I didn't need to go to rehab. I just want to say
that um I was you mischaracterized it completely.
Is there any way that I can get a free subscription to your only
fans laugh? No, there's no way that you can get a free sub. Everybody
says they're not interested unless it's a black guy laugh. Unlucky.
It's not a black guy, but he has a huge thick. So, can I get
a discount?
Rip the off if you buy that video. I promise you.
No, you are. It's a It's a faceing video.
Listen, the first one ever. I'm a little nervous.
I said all that about how you'd never do Only Fans again and
it was so wrong for you to have done it in the first place and
for and then and then I got accepted into a very good school.
I don't even hold that. Hold on. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Okay.
Go ahead. Do you remember our first conversation? I was like
how you talked about how you couldn't find like your husband
attractive because he wouldn't treat you in like a rough way
at all. He liked you too much and and you were like crying about
that on stream. You freaked the [__] out of me. You
freaked the [__] out of me for bringing that up because
it was about You're you're you're like you're This is not true
and you're lying. It is true. Wait, it is true. You said your
familiar boyfriend. We've had this conversation. Hold on. You
tied this
convers because your boyfriend wouldn't treat you before and
you couldn't get turned on and you felt like that was [__]
up, right? That really [__] up. This was not a problem.
This was never a problem. Okay. You are mischaracterizing something
I said. Wait, what am I mischaracterizing? You pull up that video.
I really wish I had the video. What am I What am I You said what
am I mischaracterizing that you said? I'm sure you have. It doesn't
matter. You can just say what what I'm mischaracterizing. What
did I just mischaracterize? We've had this conversation multiple
times. I'm not going to talk about a past relationship because
it's a disrespectful to my current relationship. And I'm not
gonna do your little dance monkey dance for you when your your
your viewers are dwindling. I know you need this. I know you
need this and I'm not gonna give it to you.
I wouldn't give it to you. Now you're talking about how you're
getting face. I wonder if that turns you on and if you wish your
husband done that to you before. You are. Remember when you said
that you were never going to do content like this and now that
you have no money. And now that you have no money, you have to
do [__] like this. I have no money. That's crazy.
Like this. I'm sorry that after seeing what you really look like,
you lost. Hold on. You just keep You keep referencing what Dashi
said is my dog and now you're wondering why I'm being like a
little bit hostile to you on stream. Are you serious? So much.
Are you serious? 25 Oh, yeah. My boyfriend's running 25% off.
25% off for the first 100 people.
So, I can't get to scam, right? Run away. It's so basic. I'm
still here.
Don't answer the question.
Enough with the slurs. What question do you want me to answer?
Tell me how I misunderstood. Explain to me what you meant when
you when you said the reason you're against because it rewired
your brain and what turned you on and that your husband can never
treat you that way. Okay. So, what did I mischaracterize? A weird
relationship. I had I had a weird relationship with generally.
It had nothing to do with any relationships I was in. It it didn't
mean that it was it was him or anyone. It's the fact that I could
not it's the fact that I could not connect because of watching
too young being involved in it and the way that my life was was
uh transfire was was folding out in front of me. It had nothing
to do with any other partners. The way that you that you said
that was so disingenuous and disgusting and weird. It wasn't.
You're literally just agreeing to exactly what I said. I have
no reason to lie right now. For what reason do I have to lie
right now? I'm not even with them. Agreeing with everything I
said. Okay. You Okay. Yes. In the Yes. You worded it in a way
that was completely strange, but in some way it is true. Yes.
I didn't say Connor did anything wrong. I said you were crying
because he didn't do anything wrong and it it [__]
you up. No, I It had nothing to do with him at all. That's That's
what I Yeah. Do you understand? No, it had nothing. And no, it's
not even I didn't learn that through my experience with him either.
That's what I'm saying is that you you were like, "Oh, Connor
doesn't do any of those things. It's not like the porn I used
to watch. It's not like my previous boyfriends. It's like different,
but it's it's better and I should like it, but I can't because
my brain's been rewired by was like the general context of what
I'm talking about." I don't even think I said that because I'm
I'm not going to divulge my information with anyone, but that
was not the case. Were you advertising earlier in the stream?
Were you just advertising? Uh, no. With my current partner. I
I sure will. But I'm not going to talk about anything prior.
Only fans is a scam, right? Cuz you're not actually showing there.
So, I guess No, I am. I've No, no, no, no. I I am literally right
here saying two weeks ago that you were just going to scam people
on Only Fans. And that's how you've always done. And then Yes.
And then I realized that in one hour I could make $1,000 by scamming
them. How? No. And she came in here was like, "Your viewers are
going down, so you're going to try to make content out of me."
Wow. Sounds like you're not so different. We're not so different,
you and I.
No, we are because I'm using I'm using my body. We're really
not.
I'm using my body and my assets to make money. You're like doing
like weird little like cringe content and like trying to like
make me a LOL. This is so much different than the content we've
ever done before.
Were you on live recently and you got kicked off? Stream dad
is like number one. Like the only reason you'd be rubbing shoulders
with a guy like extreme dad ran out of Destiny content. I'm number
one. Okay. I'm literally just doing content. I've always done
when
want fighting. Put that on a t-shirt. It's the best. Right. Anyway,
dad is number one. Anyway, Lav, listen. Here's the fact of the
matter. Just to get back to the to the to the heart of the issue
why you came here. I I was not the best person I could have been
at Phillips, but I was not the worst person either. You know,
I was something in between. And at the end of the day, whatever
happened happened. I couldn't save him, but I couldn't and I
couldn't stop him. No. Well, and I've said this to you before,
ultimately, it was his choice to take drugs, but you absolutely
supplied him with them. Now, you are the genesis of that because
in the as the night that I was kicked out of his house, before
the package even arrived, you asked me a question. You said there
was a package. You Yes, there was a care package of $300. But
you asked me, "Why is Philip bragging to everybody that he's
going to steal your brick of fentinel?" And I said, "Haha, quit
playing." Because I thought you were joking with me. And you
were like, "No, seriously." And I was like, "What?" And that
caused me to ask Philillip the questions that I did in the messages
that were read earlier.
And so he did end up stealing it. And then he died. He stole
$300 from me and he used that money to buy your fentinel. He
stole the
pill to your house. My dad who got the package that was sent
and brought it to the police who I cooperated with fully would
have charged me with a crime.
Right. Uh-huh. Yeah. And I would be guilty then if I had sent
drugs to his house. But I didn't. I had sent some money. What
I This is a legal case and I'm not going to talk about it further.
have I You are definitely That is not the way that things went
down. Especially with You are the only one who has said differently.
You are the Would you Would you defend Destiny not talking about
his case, the Pixie stuff, or do you think Destiny should talk
about it, Lav? Wait, what? So, you just said you're not going
to talk about a legal case. So, you sound just like Kylo, right?
When she says she won't talk about Destiny's cases, and it's
okay for him to not talk about the Pixie case. You defend that?
I think Yeah. I'm not talking No, I'm not talking about it for
the sake of Extreme Dad. I'm talking about it for the sake of
Philip and his family. Yeah. Yeah. You're the only one who has
made his death into a spectacle into content for the Kylie didn't
talk. If Kylie didn't talk about the legal thing because of Pixie,
because it could harm Pixie, that would be good. That That'd
be fine. But she's not talking about it because of Destiny, which
is the problem. So that's it. No. Are you going to still accuse
me of being a drug addict? He doesn't want No. Well, so he didn't
repeat the claims, Lab. So to to make him kind of own up to what
he said earlier, he didn't actually say the thing about the party.
He didn't say anything about the Quanipin. he said is that he
saw your streams and that you had scratched up arms and that
you itch your arms a lot. So I think it's a little bit disingenuous
for extreme dad now to say, "Oh, it was the Billy, you know,
uh the, you know, party or whatever with the Wolfson Park White."
Yeah. You insinuated she was a junkie who was obviously insinuating
she was shooting up. I was kidding. I was just like having fun
with She shoots up drugs. Yeah, exactly. was he wasn't
obviously don't shoot up drugs. I have eczema and it's springtime.
Yeah. So you say convince it good luck convincing a jury of that.
Yeah. Yeah. Turn me in. And will you cooperate with the police
as I did? I will. All right. You heard it here first, folks.
So we're going to hold you to that. Anyway, I appreciate you
coming on. Thank you so much.
Get out. You heard him live. Get the out of here. Get going.
Yeah. Thank you so much, Only Fans. 25% off for the first 100
subs.
I suck for the first time on camera. For the first time. Not
for the first time in real life, right? I don't even know why
I asked that question, but I just I was trying to be nice on
the spot. Not
okay. Who believes her? Who believes a word out of her mouth?
Oh, the moon. She's a trustworthy.
Uh anyway, literally the the the only reason why I have problems
with this whole or thing, the only reason why people think that
I'm a murderer responsible for Philip's death is because of Lav
going on Tom Foolery's stream and calling me a murderer. Yeah,
that's somewhere.
That's a VOD, right? That's up still online, right? Is when she
called you a murder. Oh my god, I found it. You guys, I found
it. I found it. I found it. You found your found cool, you guys.
I found it. Oh my god, I found
it. Hold on. Hold on. Oh my god, this is so great. What did you
find? Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Holding. I like the avatar
there. The the judgment. This work. It's not working. Okay. Well,
it there you are. Here you go. Hey, bring these up on stream,
please. Okay. What are we looking at here? You got to tell the
second one is the first one. It starts with question mark. What
Okay, we've got the logs. Apparently, Extreme Dad has found the
logs. I have. I'm so glad that I did. Whose logs, by the way,
here exactly? Uh, this is between Lav and Extreme Dad.
What happened? He got on and said he was going to take your fentanel
shipment. What the [__] Frank, shut up. Frank, Frank,
10 bucks. This This extreme that more like extreme.
Come on. Don't Don't Hold on. Well, I don't know. The the donation
cut out, Frank, but thank you very much for the donation. I appreciate
it, buddy. Uh, shut up. There was no fentanyl shipment. Stop
trying to cause problems. I hate him enough already. Do your
do your worst. He's aing loser and deserves what he gets. Wait,
I'm not joking. He said you were sending fentanel to his house
and his dad kicked you out and he was just going to take it.
Oh, did he? Wait, hold on, though. Wait, was Lab the one Lab
was the one who told you this and then the next day? Yes, she
is the genesis of that entire thing. She's the only person who
has said it or like she's the she is the source of the lie. Yes.
Well then why why did you just message him and say why are you
been telling people you're going to steal my stuff when she said
it was fentanyl? Because I didn't believe her. That's why I was
like shut up there. Stop trying to cause problems. Cuz I thought
she was just making it up. But when he was like when she said
and his dad kicked you out and he was just going to take it.
I was like, "Well, hold on. There is truth to that." And I didn't
want to tell him, "Hey, actually, there's $300 in this package."
I didn't want him to know what was in it, but I knew obviously
that it wasn't right. I I didn't. And and I obviously knew that
it wasn't fentanyl. And that's why I thought that she was just
making that up to cause problems so that I would give her his
address so she could get him arrested. Okay. Wait, I'm not joking.
You should just turn him into the cops. You You should just unironically
turn them into the cops. Okay. And then what else do we have
here? There's one other one. It's this, which is from way later.
You said you'd send me your phone number. Yeah, but people who
were actually involved already have my phone number, and I don't
see how giving it to someone who has a clearly shown me hostile
intent is a good idea. On a sec on second thought, what do you
want it for exactly? To give it to the police like you said I
could. Are you stupid? A little. His dad has my name and number.
Don't you think he would have given it to them if he wanted to
go further with this? No. He's Grievous's child. You said you
give it to me. What is your phone number? Okay. I don't know
why I included that one. I just got a little excited.
Why? Why would people mailing you cash?
Because I was in I was across the country in Yeah, but there
there like things to do that with, right? No, because I had lost
my ID and or No, he didn't have ID. my friend didn't have ID
and um my uh account my bank account was overdrawn from our rental
car thing and so I couldn't get like a a cash app or anything
like that and he couldn't Western Union it to me. So he was like,
"Can I just send you cash?" Why couldn't he Western Union it
to you? Cuz he didn't have ID. So um he was like, "Can I just
send you cash? I'll put it in the mail today." And I asked Philip,
I said, "Can I get a package here?" And he said, "Yeah, here's
the address." And so I was like, "Cool." I gave him the address
and he said, "Put it in the mail. It's package. I mean, it was
an envelope. It was an envelope rather, you know. Okay. Care
package is just like it was, you know. But yeah, and the fact
of the matter is is that I've complied with the police. I've
opened myself up for questioning where, you know, I've I've been
I've done everything to cooperate. And at the end of the day,
everyone agrees that I'm not in any way responsible legally,
criminally, or morally for what happened. Lav is the only person
who has any sort ofing other story than that. Lav is the only
person. Okay. And as you saw, she used it toing promote her Only
fans. Okay. Anyway, I have to go.
Okay.
or I can stay if you want me to, but I mean like No, I just listen.
I feel like the idea that somebody would just send you cash in
the mail is a little crazy. But
is he just going on mute or
I I don't know. Maybe he meant to try to DC and then he went
muted. Okay. All right. Well, thanks for coming on, guys. Wait.
I'm back. Do you want me to say or have we pretty much covered
it all? Um, no, we're good. I'm good. I think we're good. Take
it easy. Hey, I appreciate you having me on like always, Riyle.
Um, I'm glad that you your title doesn't
uh insinuate. I'm a Destiny Defender and um yeah, I just hope
everybody was accusations. Okay. Well, yeah. Well, I mean, uh,
hey, I ain't going to, you know, at the end of the day, uh, Gotcha.
I would I would uh hide your kids. Um, extreme dads on the loose.
You know what I mean? You guys are all both 18 though, right?
All right, see you guys. I'm gonna need some IDs. All right,
later. Bye. 15k people showed up for Polyv's rally in Niscu tonight.
Doesn't matter he's cooked. Doesn't matter. He tore cooked. It's
over. Wow, that was a crazy conversation. I don't know. I feel
like I'm very suspect that this guy did not get any
right. Am I crazy that I feel like it was definitely drugs? I
feel like it was not cash at all. I But also, I don't believe
he would have told the guy what was in it. So then again, I don't
think he would have told the guy, "Hey, it's fentanyl, right?"
I don't think he would have told him that. Yeah, I don't think
so. You told the exact same story in your voice chat one night.
Oh, crazy, crazy, crazy. Okay. Well, what do we I'm just getting
like other people being like,
um, hey, just so you know, story is suspicious. They're doing
drugs together." He might have asked, "Can I have can I get more
fentinel delivered here for us?" I have no idea. You seriously
think Carney's winning? I just don't see any chance at all personally
that the Conservative Party of Canada turns it around. I think
I think they've been totally seeded by Trump. Trump like
horribly. It's totally over on that front. All right, what else
do we have for today? Oh, there's like actually other drama stuff
that we can kind of get to. Hold on. Okay, we're going to do
I'll do the Vitali update and then I think we might just go back
to Karen Reed stuff. We'll see. We'll see how it goes. All right.
All right. You would just cash out 300 bucks. Well, he said he
couldn't cash out. He had like so many excuses for how he couldn't
take money. That was just weird. It was very weird.
Veryad.